Being a highly creative woman,
I find myself fearful that having kids
will be spiritual suicide,
hindering my endeavors,
but I also don't want to have an
unfulfilled life.
Can I have a full life without kids?
Well,
yes,
I.
I suspect you can.
Although it's risky because it's really
important for people to have kids
because the thing is is that you get
older than 40 and our culture is kind of
dopey in that regards.
It's underdeveloped.
We live as if we live as if we.
We only exist when we're young and we
don't.
It's like,
what are you going to do from the ages
of say,
45 to 90 or 95?
You,
you need a family around you.
You need to see your children grow,
you need to have grandchildren.
It's a major part,
maybe the most important part of the
last half of life.
No.
You said being a highly creative woman,
I find myself fearful that having kids
will be spiritual suicide.
Well,
that's the part of your question that I
would really address because I would
say,
well,
don't let them be spiritual suicide.
You know?
It may be that there's a certain amount
of time that you need to take away from
the kids that,
and this is the case for parents in
general,
um,
so that you can pursue your own creative
endeavors.
It's children do not have to devour your
life.
In fact,
if you let them devour your life,
then you'll hate them and you mistreat
them.
And so what you want to do is to set
yourself up so that you can have
children and have a life and that's
better for the children and it's better
for you.
Like children can be taught,
encouraged to spend a fair bit of time,
not when they're infants,
obviously,
but to spend a fair bit of time amusing
themselves.
And that's especially the case if you
have more than one child because they'll
mutually amuse one another.
It's actually easier in some ways to
have more than one child because with
one child you're constantly abusing the
child,
but with two or three,
then they're off in their little club.
Especially if you can stop them from
developing sibling rivalry,
that's too intense and they can monitor
themselves.
So the trick is,
if you're a highly creative woman is be
disagreeable it now so that you can
carve yourself out your own space so
that you don't come to resent your
children.
You're afraid of that.
You're afraid that it looks like you're
afraid that if you,
if you give yourself two children,
there'll be nothing left for you.
And um,
you know,
that can happen if you have children who
have terrible health problems,
for example,
but you can't protect yourself against
those eventualities in life anyways.
But I would say your best bet is to be a
more selfish mother.
And believe me,
I've had more clients who were ruined by
mothers who were too unselfish than.
I've had clients who were ruined by
mothers who were too selfish.
So,
um,
you need to be there when the kids need
you,
but you shouldn't be there any more than
is necessarily.
So
let's see.
Adam Watts's,
I feared having kids for the same
reason.
I'm a full time pro artist.
You make your own normal.
Said,
my therapist.
Jp is speaking the truth.
Yeah,
well that's,
that's the thing.
You know,
don't be thinking that you can't
organize your life when you have
children.
The thing about modern people is that
they're terrified of children.
They in this because they think they
regard children as if they're miniature
tyrants and they can be of course,
because anyone will tyrannized over you
if you allow them to perhaps not anyone
but virtually anyone.
Why not regulate your children's
behavior?
I wrote a chapter in my new book called,
don't let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them and that's like
really serious advice is like if you
allow your children to conduct
themselves around you in a manner that
makes you dislike them.
If you're being honest,
if you're paying attention to the shadow
side of yourself that can be aggressive
and destructive,
then then you're.
If you allow your children to do things
that make you dislike them,
then they're going to.
They're having children is going to mess
up your life,
but you don't have to do that.
You're actually.
You actually have a tremendous amount of
control over the quality of your
relationship with your children and also
the manner in which you choose to
disperse your time and I mean you're,
you've got,
if you're willing to think it through
and be clear,
you can be in charge of your household.
The children don't have to be in charge
and it's not good for them to be in
charge anyways.
So people are afraid of children and
it's too bad because children are
absolutely wonderful.
I mean,
you have to be careful with them and
they get tired and they get hungry and
they get hot and,
and they don't have an attention span.
That's as long as an adult who has a
long attention span,
but they're great company and they're
unbelievably comical and they love you.
And like they,
they give back far more than they take
if you have an ounce of sense when
you're dealing with them.
So yeah.
So,
so don't be afraid of children,
man.
You're,
you're the adult for God's sake.
You've got the upper hand and and if you
have a partner you can rely on,
well then you know you can both decide
how it is that you're going to run your
household so that you're actually
thrilled to death,
that you have kids and that you have a
life.